[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a south korean space western
film called space sweepers spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
in the year 2098 the fading of sunlight
and acidic soil has caused all the
plants to disappear the earth has run
out of fertile land forests have
vanished and deserts are widespread in
such conditions the end of humanity
seemed near but a company called the uts
corporation came to mankind's aid and
built a new orbiting home for humanity
that mimics natural processes on earth
it is a mass of land a little distant
from earth that orbits alongside it
however the uts was not competent enough
to build a home that can accommodate
everyone from earth only a chosen few
who have enough money to pay for the uts
services can ascend to the new orbiting
home to become the uts citizens while 95
of the human population remains on the
dying earth
in addition some humans called the space
sweepers live on several less developed
constellation colonies called the orbits
space sweepers put their lives in danger
to collect unwanted trash from space
like abandoned satellites and space
vehicles they sell such debris to the
uts warehouse to make their living the
ceo of uts james sullivan claims that he
cares about the people on the earth but
cannot do anything about it he is also
planning to create a civilization on
mars making it the new earth at the
beginning of the movie a space sweeper
named kim tae ho arrives at the uts lost
and found warehouse where things and
people who have been found in orbit are
kept he is there to have a look at a
seven-year-old girl who was recently
found dead
after paying with his magnetic shoes he
gets to see the girl but he is
disheartened to see she isn't the one he
is looking for
tejo then ascends back to space and to
his orbit ship called the victory
tejo's crew consists of a former drug
dealer named tiger park an android
called bubs and is led by captain jang
the crew get on the ship victory and fly
to intercept an abandoned spaceship that
had been floating in space
the victory is late as they see other
space sweepers competing to claim the
ship as their own
but under the captainship of jang they
impressively managed to get their hands
on the spaceship the crew brings the
ship to a waste management factory only
to find that the damage they had caused
while capturing it is more expensive
than the ship itself the crew plans to
fix the damage themselves to get the
money but while they are at it they
discover something strange inside the
spacecraft has a living little girl in a
space suit the shocked crew get her out
and bring her with them to their ship
they plan to get a reward from the
girl's parents for bringing her back as
they deliberate on the plan the news
shows the picture of the girl it says
that the girl is an android named
dorothy who has a weapon of mass
destruction inside of her created by the
terrorist group black fox
hearing that the girl is dangerous the
group gets away from her while planning
about getting rid of her tahoe sees
several missed calls from a man named
hyun wu kang on dorothy's phone he
recognizes the man as a uts employee and
a doctor tejo calls kang and demands 2
million dollars to give dorothy back to
him kang accepts the deal which makes
the group jump in happiness they decide
to meet in the 32 commercial district
however both the groups are unaware of
the ceo james listening to their
conversation from afar james wants the
little girl dorothy for himself because
according to him only she can help him
execute his plan to colonize mars james
then sends off his men to get the girl
meanwhile taeho and the crew meet dr
kang to hand him the girl only to find
that she is missing the little girl
somehow ends up in a club where everyone
recognizes her and starts to panic they
run away from the girl in fear as she
stays still on the dance floor just then
dr kang finds her and runs to get the
girl but is dragged away by the
panicking crowd the space guards sent by
james are also there they fire at tejo
but dorothy with her supernatural powers
creates a shield to protect him the crew
somehow escapes with dorothy on their
ship
now everyone is at a loss for what they
should do with the girl tiger begins to
open up to her playing with her to keep
her occupied at the same time captain
jang sees a drawing of her that dorothy
had made the crew starts to feel
affectionate towards her as time goes by
the following day captain jang notices
that a tomato plant has grown in their
ship
later the android bubz tells dorothy
about the crew's past it turns out that
all of the crew members once used to be
wealthy and good people tahoe was a
commander of the space guards and the
first ever uts genius he worked closely
with ceo james back then during one of
his missions he found a human baby that
he was supposed to send back to the
earth but tahoe chose to take care of
the little girl instead he named the
girl sunni and treated her as his own
child after being her dad tejo could not
kill people anymore so james labeled him
useless and threw him out of the uts
tahoe was demoted to a slum orbit colony
where he stayed without a home for a
year one day the orbit was hit by space
debris and during the chaos he got
separated from his daughter
since then he has been trying to
accumulate money to conduct a search
party for her later they get a call from
a person who wants to take dorothy for a
lot of money taeho prepares to hand her
off to them but tiger is worried about
what the people will do to the little
girl tejo reminds him that he needs to
look for his daughter sunni at any cost
as they talk someone kidnaps dorothy
from the bathroom the crew soon realizes
and chases the abductor they get the
little girl and defeat the abductor and
his group when the team reveals the
abductor's face they are surprised to
see that he is kerum the manager of the
garbage disposal facility they sell the
space debris to
captain jang interrogates the abductors
and finds out that dorothy is actually a
human and not an android she was born
with a congenital disease and couldn't
move so her father dr kang injected her
with nanobots found in space debris as a
last resort to save her life the
nanobots not only saved dorothy but also
gave her unique powers she could
communicate with other nanobots and heal
and protect things such as the tomato
plant that had grown on the ship
james found this and used little dorothy
to turn mars into a healthy green planet
but now since her job for him is done he
wants to kill her he knows that dorothy
has powers to heal the earth and make it
fertile again but if she does that
humans won't need him and the uts would
be out of power so to end the problem as
a whole james created a hydrogen bomb
and labeled dorothy as dangerous he
plans to explode the bomb that will kill
all humans on the earth making mars the
only viable option for all other humans
the crew finds out the kerum and his
friends are called black fox they are an
environmentalist group but james has
mislabeled them as terrorists and plans
to blame the hydrogen bomb attack on
earth on them the group is surprised by
the revelation as they process the
information space guards sent by james
arrive in their orbit the crew narrowly
manages to escape the orbit in their
ship but are pursued by the soldiers
while trying to flee they enter a danger
zone filled with millions of nanobots
dorothy uses her power to communicate
with the nanobots and saves the ship
from malfunctioning however she falls
unconscious right after
tiger performs cpr on the little girl
and finally manages to bring her back
she wakes up with a fart everyone in the
crew sighs in relief and laughs with her
they communicate with the black fox
group and plan to reunite dorothy with
her father dr kang the two ships meet
and the little girl finally gets to meet
her father everyone is delighted to see
them hug but the happiness doesn't last
long when suddenly they are attacked by
the space guards they barge in and kill
kang and all of the black fox group
james is there too he hands tahoe and
the crew four million dollars for
keeping the girl safe and leaves with
dorothy james also orders his soldiers
to keep an eye on the victory ship and
the crew after everyone is gone tiger
tells the crew that they will have to
rescue dorothy but tahoe wants to take
the money to save his own daughter they
get into a fight which ends after
captain zhang asks taeho to continue
with saving his daughter but the other
crew will be on a mission to save
dorothy the crew prepares for their
missions as tejo reminisces about sunni
to the crew's delight he decides to join
them to save dorothy all of them take
their respective positions ready for the
mission with all their skills they
manage to keep up with the space guards
who fire at them repeatedly the victory
manages to get away from the guards and
finally reaches the place where dorothy
is located they discover the little girl
scared and tied to a chair with the
hydrogen bomb captain zhang figures out
that the bomb can destroy everything
within 5 000 kilometers they have to fly
away as soon as they can but the group
feels responsible for the bomb that is
about to kill billions of people on
earth they cannot leave when they have a
chance to save so many lives so the crew
contacts all their fellow space sweepers
and asks for their help to escape the
space guards who are waiting for them
outside with their help they managed to
get away from the facility and fly far
away the space sweepers and guards get
into a battle but the guards are soon
defeated only one guard ship remains
which is piloted by james himself
captain jang figures out a way to
broadcast all of james's doings to the
entire world now everyone knows about
his plan to destroy the earth the
victory finally reaches 5 000 kilometers
away from the earth just then james's
ship latches itself onto the victory he
expects to see dorothy inside but
instead is surprised to come across the
hydrogen bomb it turns out that the crew
had put the hydrogen bomb into their own
ship and sent dorothy off with the other
space sweepers before fleeing themselves
they have decided to sacrifice their own
life in order to take the bomb away from
the earth now finally the bomb explodes
taking james and the whole of the ship
victory with it but ensuring that
everyone else is safe as the dust from
the explosion settles we see the victory
ship has been protected by nanobots
thanks to dorothy all the crew members
are happy and grateful to the little
girl the world has started to heal and
fertile lands are coming back with the
help of dorothy's powers dorothy also
helps tejo reunite with his daughter
sunni using her abilities the group
returns to their job as space sweepers
now with an upgraded ship more money and
dorothy added to their team
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching